Well, if you can message Aaron in that same group and ask them if they're gonna join.
I'm sending that.
Not strike, strike the base deal, just in that group where you B5 are there, no, and then Mike and B3.
What?
Drop a message there, tag, tag both of them, and ask them if they're joining. If they don't reply, then you can drop in, drop the swag e-mail.
And you're doing.
Yes, yes.
How many are covering?
Singh.
Hey, gentlemen, are we waiting for Mike?
Yeah.
What did he say, Vishal?
No response.
Stop an e-mail.
Yep.
You tagged both Aaron and Mike both?
Yes.
Can you, can you check their data? Doesn't they accept the E. white or no, no E. white?
Busy.
Erin is away, Mike is busy. Oh, okay.
That's fine, did they accept the invite, or did it deny it, but it will be checked, check that too, otherwise Gregory.
No response, no response.
Okay.
Kaika Jaan.